[Musique]
le virus qui repart à la hausse nous
renouons avec les chiffres de ces
derniers mois près de vingt mille
nouveaux cas de kobe d'enregistrer hier
le chiffre de vingt mille il faut
peut-être faire attention parce que ça
survient après un week-end du 11
novembre mais en tout cas on il ya une
accélération
nous avons notre destin en main cela
passe par le vaccin cela passe par le
respect attentif des gestes barrières le
port du masque c'était hier soir dans
les salles du ministère de l'intérieur
français françaises faites ce que je dis
ne faites pas ce que je fais ll e l
yelle ce petit mot de trois lettres est
apparu dans l'édition numérique du
dictionnaire le petit robert ce pronom
et la contraction de ils et elles
couramment utilisés au sein de la
communauté lgbt il est employé pour
désigner une personne qui ne se
reconnaît ni comme omnicom femmes et
françois jolivet donc un député de la
majorité député de l'indre il est
carrément parti voilà le voici il est
carrément l'a carrément écrit à
l'académie française il se dit stupéfait
par l'arrivée de ce terme de les motiver
vrai qu'ils disaient il dit ceci
l'avènement d' idéologie walk dans notre
langue jean michel blanquer a réagi
l'écriture inclusive n'est pas l'avenir
de la langue française alors même que
nos élèves sont justement en train de
consolider leurs savoirs fondamentaux il
ne saurait avoir cela pour référence
eric zemmour de nouveau face à la
justice il comparaît devant le tribunal
correctionnel de paris pour avoir
qualifié les mineurs isolés de voleur
assassin et violeur c'est certainement
excessif mais il ya un vrai problème de
mineurs isolés c'est pas moi qui le dit
75% des faits sont commis par des
mineurs isolés source communiqué du
parquet de paris et puis aujourd'hui
s'ouvre la 18e édition de la journée des
records du monde du guinness book des
records assez c'est un festival situé à
10 minutes à pied de la place bellecour
le quartier de la guillotière est
gangrénée par la délinquance centre de
toutes les crispations ce marché sauvage
qui se tient tous les jours
nous y propose à la sauvette des
cigarettes 5 euros le paquet les
bagarres ils sont courantes parmi les
gens qui avaient été arrêtés donc quand
même environ 6000 personnes qui ont été
interpellées 70 qui avaient été
incarcérés nous avions 40 % de mineurs
non accompagnés
donc voila cela pose un problème le
record de la voiture tirée sur le plus
de m en marchant sur les mains vous avez
bien entendu alors regardez un chinois
de 70 kg a tiré une voiture pesant plus
d'une tonne que la personnalité du jour
c'est une femme originaire d'argentine
qui a guéri du sida sans traitement elle
avait été diagnostiquée séropositive en
2013 elle est parvenue à se débarrasser
du virus ashley watson pour le salto
arrière les plus éloignées entre deux
barres horizontales
c'est ça ouais c'est ça si m quand même
fallait faire le gymnaste professionnels
et youtuber britannique a battu son
propre la barre des 140 mille adhérents
les républicains a été franchie ils
choisiront leur candidat pour la
présidentielle entre le 1er et le 4
décembre vous savez pourquoi ils sont
nombreux à avoir rejoint les
républicains c'est parce que le 4
décembre donc pas choisir le candidat
des républicains ils peuvent choisir le
prochain président de la république ce
salon pour vous c'est l'occasion de
venir chercher des parrainages oui mais
tu vois j'arrive à me lis donc je peux
ensuite vous avez un américain qui a
sauté entre cinq taxis londoniens avec
un pogo stick comprenait un bâton
sauteur
bonjour vous allez bien bien quotidien
avec vous quotidien ça va bien notre
homme du jour david lisnard le maire ait
l'air de cannes a été élu à la tête de
l'association des maires de france oui
si j'ai des maires je voterai david
lisnard oui parce que c'est le candidat
anti macron
je pas le premier critère mais poussé
par mauvais critère south cbi et enfin
le record du monde du saut périlleux en
arrière sur un pied à maroc à la fai a
cumulé un total incroyable de douze
sauts en 30 secondes